I created a brand called get more
proudware it is underwear for female to
male transgender people who have not had
their bottom surgery yet
which is swapping out what genitalia you
have so my underwear they already have a
bulge in them
if you look at a guy's crotch wearing
wearing shorts you're not going to see a
bulge barely ever but if you're a trans
guy just knowing that there's nothing
there and there's nothing under it's
it sucks
so trans person female to male they have
to wear a packer which is like a fake
limp penis and then they have to wear a
harness to hold it in place and then
they have to put their underwear on and
that is a lot of work and it's heavy
and then you can see it's already
starting to puff up
I came up with the idea for my business
because Packers fall out your pants
one day when I was younger
I was actually swimming and lo and
behold guess what I'm swimming this way
and my sock is swimming that way and I'm
like oh crap so I'm just like oh that's
not mine I'm like uh no we're not doing
this today
and
thank you
is nice and bright
I love the feedback that I get from
customers a lot of people they'll write
me saying I love your underwear so much
you make me so much more confident
the final product looks like this it has
a bulge in it
you have like
a bulge right there like I actually made
a product that people wear on a regular
basis
sometimes not all of them come out which
sucks because this foam is very very
expensive I make the Packers myself and
I sew them into the underwear but I do
get the underwear manufactured
about a year ago I went to Columbia to
look for a new supplier
in Colombia looking for somebody to sew
my Underpants I met Isabelle
[Music]
we met at our mutual friend's house and
I was like damn girl she fine like she
is so beautiful like I'm like ah like my
heart is like melting we definitely had
immediate chemistry like I felt like our
heart was like a boom like there was a
string and it was like you don't have to
say anything but it's like you're you
feel it like your chest just wants to be
like uh all the way to them that's how
exactly how I felt
that night we went out
we was kissing we was dancing we was
hugging it was a great night and
Isabelle told me that she doesn't have
sex on the first night which I was kind
of relieved because she did not know
that I was trans
[Music]